[Music]
so glad to have you here we as you know
we announced data prep this morning and
so I had to obscurely title this talk I
mean it's fitting fitting title but but
it couldn't be as descriptive as I
wanted so maybe you are the few that
actually knew what you were coming to
today maybe you read you you understood
the code if so congratulations yes
so I'm Eric Anderson I'm the product
manager for cloud data prep so we
announced it this morning for the first
time publicly which I'm super excited
about I can finally tell my wife what I
do at work no it's not that bad
but um and she is here tonight so you
can give her a hard time so cloud data
prep as you know or as you may have
heard it's intelligent visual and
service data preparation interface that
runs on Google clouds data services a
quick overview on what we're going to
cover today and maybe to recap the
announcement it is available today in
private beta which means to select users
and then we plan in the coming weeks for
this to be available I'm sorry weeks or
months I don't want to promise anything
or get you set to expectations is to be
available publicly in a public beta
we're gonna start with the need for data
preparation then go into the to benefit
pillars for data prep so first the the
visual and interactive interface that
we've described previously and you saw
today this morning as well as the
serverless aspects how these are
executed without any configuration on
your part at basically any scale and
we'll wrap up with a couple examples and
spend most of our time which is where I
think you'd like it
in a demonstration so the need for data
preparation and I'm sorry to pull out
the same numbers you've seen before but
it's part of the routine you have to do
this as you may know or may feel 76% of
day professionals say that this is the
least enjoyable part of their work I
this it's like flossing or maybe doing
the dishes it sounds like
80% of professionals time is in data
preparation so if we were to structure
this conference like you do your data
time I'd be talking for like three days
straight and the ml team would have like
30 minutes and nobody wants to hear from
me for three days straight
so let's figure out what's going on and
how we can fix data preparation first
the cast and crew of those involved
there tends to be kind of a spectrum or
at least camps of people there's the
business folks who are close to the
problem the need for the data and then
there are those with the data skills the
data scientists or engineers as we might
call them it turns out that all of these
people have data preparation needs and
problems and cloud data prep is you see
today we think solves problems for all
these people in although they do have
their common tools today some of them
available on Google cloud platform or
within the G suite so I don't mean to
discount those tools these are great
tools and if you're comfortable with
them stick with them in particular if
we're talking about data preparation
data studio is a wonderful place for
data scientists in an easy to set up and
familiar ipython like environment but
today we're gonna talk about data prep
and and to get you geared on again why
we need data preparation I just want to
start with this kind of analogy that
we're going from raw to refined data and
people have an ask oh so what is this
raw data that needs all this cleaning
well you've seen it before this is this
is logs billing data transactions and
the reason why we're doing the cleaning
is because as soon as you try and
visualize this or run a report you
realize that oh there's these null
values and that you prefer these things
in column different columns so that you
could sort by them very quickly the need
for data preparation Rises and then you
spend 80% of your time doing it so let's
use a motivating example throughout this
on that we can refer to for why we're
doing this data prep imagine
you're one of these line of business
users I refer to your you're more
familiar with sheets or maybe sequel
every now and then and you'd like to
measure the impact and value of your
customer support portal specifically web
chat will say hypothetically the first
thing you might have to do is figure out
where all this data lives and then
you're gonna have to do some cleaning as
we mentioned and you're you're going to
realize through that process you need to
structure it a little bit differently
enrich it these are the steps that I'm
referring to is data preparation and as
mentioned you probably have the skills
to do this so if you were to try and do
this on your own today you might first
enlist the help of an expert
we'll call the data scientist but it's
somebody who can find and understand the
data sources you're looking to use so
this data scientist is going to go
through basically that same process we
described but they're going to do it in
a way that you might not understand it's
like ninja scripts as they're called in
Python their views are and other people
in the room are going to think oh that's
such a bad idea and then your sequel and
and they're gonna take us there probably
do this on a sample of the data and then
use it on their local machine and
they're gonna return that this to you
and you're gonna say great so this has
all the answers and they're like
actually this is just a sample and if
you really want to run this every day
we're gonna have to get a data engineer
involved so so you're already like a
week or two into this project can get
the data engine revolved and they do
more or less the same thing but this
time they're gonna do it in Java and
they're gonna add unit tests and they're
gonna run it on Hadoop and they they
have this whole environment set up so
you don't have to worry about it but now
you're another two or three weeks into
the process and and people are asking
you for funding so you're getting
executive stakeholders involved and
maybe you don't want to go through this
in order to measure the impact I might
be a little bit overdramatic but I might
not actually so this is where we think
data prep can help it helps you do this
in your own workstation on your own time
in the moment you need to do it so let's
get in to telling you about that first
benefit pillar
the visual interactive interface but
before that I want you to be able to
contrast this with how we do it today so
I've done some of this kind of data
science II type work and I have
basically a little cocktail of queries
and scripts that I like to throw with a
new data set because I have to
understand if this thing is exactly what
it's called how fresh it is and
basically I'm treating data like a black
box I don't actually look at the data I
just kind of poke and prod it to
understand it this is one approach
another oh I'm sorry
whereas data prep just throws you right
into your data rather than feeling
through a dark room for furniture we
throw the flood lights on and you see
your data and you can interact with it
immediately we'll take a quick tour of
some of the elements in the user
interface so you get a feel for them the
first thing you're probably noticing is
you're seeing distributions along the
top of your data each column is profiled
to understand the distribution is
presented in histograms and in ranges in
the case of like Geographic data or
other data that's easily described
different ways we can throw it on a map
in the case of a time series we display
it in a time series you're also seeing
at the top a type for each column and
you're seeing as well a mostly green bar
maybe a little bit of black and red in
there this is telling you how well that
column actually fits in that type so
data prep is detected the type and if
it's all green then in fact all the
values are valid along that type if
you're seeing some black there are
missing values red then these are
actually invalid a chord in that type
you can adjust the type as necessary you
can also create custom types if the 17
available immediately in data prep don't
suit you and there's also a series of
date and time types so we kind of got
types covered
this was the other kind of motivating
example so traditional ETL tools put you
in kind of a logic centric view so if
you want to apply transformations of the
data you typically see a block of where
your data came from a transformation may
be a join but at this point towards the
end of my pipeline I don't quite know
what my data looks like and it's hard to
have a mental model of what I need to
apply into next in the case of data prep
we just showed you how you have a mental
model of your data when you're
visualizing the data grid and there it's
easy to detect what kind of
transformation you want to apply to next
you can either use the cues that we've
provided for you in the distributions
you might detect an outlier or didn't
want to transform the missing or invalid
values or if you see some other kind of
anomaly all you do is just highlight or
click the data and what data prep begins
to do is suggest the transformation it
thinks you're you're kind of invoking by
this highlight it may take a highlight
or two in order to derive it the
precisely the transformation you want
these suggestions are shown at the
bottom and you'll see that they have
kind of sub suggestions within a
suggestion so you can alter the
suggestion is necessary and then apply
it to your data set so that you can
apply one transformation that way but
generally applying lots of
transformations a clean here clean there
some structuring and reaching these
transformations are added up in it what
we call a recipe it's a little more
approachable than the word script
perhaps and recipes and data prep may be
slightly different than sequel or Python
are human readable or at least human
readable to most humans and they are
hidden by default so if you you know if
you're the line of business user who
just wants to make a few changes and and
doesn't want to learn the world it's
very easy and approachable but as you
continue use data prep and if you become
a power user it's also very expressive
you won't need to feel like you're held
back by some of the
data prep because script these recipes
still behave like scripts the export you
can apply advanced functions within them
and the recipe itself can be reordered
inserted undo rewind play forward roll
back that all means the same thing just
adding and adding to it so you've
explored your data you've applied some
transformations they just looking a lot
cleaner but really typically with these
projects you're trying to you know put
the data in a new place in a new form
they're still shaping and reaching to do
and joins tend to be the hardest part at
least for you know the sequel newbies
I'll put myself in that bucket I still
get a little bit anxious when I have to
do a joint and figure out the keys so
when you say wait in data prep you'll be
looking at a single data set you'll
choose to add a new data set you'll see
a preview so all along the way you're
kind of knowing you're on the right
track I've got my original data set I
got my preview and then when you select
to join we we detect common Keys as
they're called common fields that are
likely to be joinable and you can choose
the the keys that you want to include of
these and then go ahead and start
choosing all the columns really joining
isn't so much of a scary process as much
as just selecting what you want from the
two tables and shipping it off as a new
step in your in your recipe of
transformations you'll notice that
basically everything is a step in your
recipe of transformations renaming
things joining enriching which makes
these recipes portable because they
contain all the necessary steps
including formatting and that so it's a
shape a data set so we've done that like
a kind of a world run tour of the the
user interface of data prep to introduce
you to the features of how you interact
with things in a visual quick way
now I mentioned quick because most of
what we do here at Google cloud we pride
ourselves in it being very scalable
so how do you how do you quickly
navigate change columns on you know up
to petabytes of data well what we
initially do in data prep is take a
sample you're always operating in the
browser on a sample of your data and you
we give you some control over that
sampling process you can make sure it's
representative and so this next bit is
about how we then take the
transformations that you've applied on
your sample and scale them out to run it
on an any size now here I draw a
contrast not to traditional ETL tools or
to you know data science approaches to
data preparation but in fact other kind
of standard approaches to the oppression
there there are other vendors and tools
out there to provide data pressuring
data preparation tooling and in those
cases what we might call
first-generation they empower business
users to apply transformation
transformations themselves but it still
gets hard when you want to scale this
out you still need to hire an IT and a
data ops team to make the cluster of
some kind you you have now multiple
vendors that providing you different
parts of the solution as you're
negotiating org wide licenses or have to
offset costs and then finally there's
this app permissions data permissions
software permissions they need to be
coordinated part of the benefit of
having this integrated into Google cloud
platform is that the execution
environment is dead simple and it's
baked right into all the permissioning
models you're used to you simply hit run
job and we spin up a dataflow job
and execute this across all the across
the entire data set so let's go into a
little bit more about how dataflow does
this for you behind the scenes these are
the steps that occur when a user clicks
run job data prep creates an Apache beam
pipeline in Java and submits that
pipeline to go out data flow so this is
a translation from your human readable
script or recipe to Java pipeline that
you may or not
be very familiar with dataflow then does
what usually does with a pipeline of
this it detects the size and pace at
which it's making progress to the data
set and auto scales is necessary it
continues to add resources optimized for
the execution of the job the job is
producing metrics monitoring metrics
that are then surfaced to an
easy-to-read UI
that you can click to if you so choose
but you I can imagine many users are
happy to not look at the monitoring UI
and as it's being processed which is
kind of unique to a data prep job and
not every day to flow job we're doing
profiling so as I mentioned the
beginning you saw a perhaps
representative sample of your data set
you saw histograms typing and values but
these are all histograms on the sample
so one of the things you might be
wondering after you execute this over
perhaps petabytes of data is that sample
the ten megabytes even representative
and so data prep was then going to
return to you a profile of your data so
here's a sample profile Amelie you're
seeing the the histograms you saw before
and the the typing and data validation
you saw before we're also seeing a
little bit more information which can
help you like I said make the decision
of whether this is in fact
representative if there any issues if
there are you can easily jump back into
your recipe take a new sample or make
the necessary Corrections and from this
view create as you can see we can also
export results and view a recipe so
you're probably wondering where this
petabyte of transformation just ended up
as with the integration with data flow
data prep is integrated with bigquery
and cloud storage as the obvious
solution
sorry storage solutions you can read
bigquery tables cloud storage files of
the expected common types and then of
course you can use these similar storage
as targets now there's a lot of other
stores
at on google cloud and we'll look to
those as well in the future and then of
course there's there's other non Google
store systems that we'd love to support
in the future but we're finding our
users in the the private alpha that
we've had previously have had no problem
keeping themselves busy with bigquery
and cloud storage and for many of our
bigquery users this is a boon for them
in terms of database migration and
schema migration so in maybe 15 or 20
minutes we've kind of covered the nuts
and bolts --is of data prep nuts and
bolts of data prep I want to go into a
demo as promised we'll spend the bulk of
our time here we just to kind of give
you some background on the demo we
mentioned earlier that our motivating
example was a line of business user who
wanted to measure the impact and quality
of the the web chat experience for their
customers I often hear this as like I
want a 360 view of my customer as we
mentioned earlier and I guess what that
means is that I want to see what the
customer experience is like when they're
learning about the product when they're
purchasing the product when they come
back for support on the product and
maybe when they're not even interacting
with the product elsewhere you know in
their daily lives businesses want to
understand users and this sense and
normally doing this is difficult but in
what we have here maybe a half hour
we're gonna see if we can get a 360 view
of our customer with the help of cloud
data prep so let's imagine you're I'm
here in my I don't need this anymore my
data prep kind of homepage and you're
already seeing a few concepts that may
be new to you so flows datasets and jobs
as listed across the top a flow is kind
of like a workspace this is where I'm
going to put a collection of files that
I'm working on for a certain project
data sets are what they sound like as
well as jobs or an execution
data flow so we're gonna create a
workspace for this project well we'll
call it 360 view because we're not
afraid of buzzwords and I'm gonna add
some datasets now let's pretend that an
engineer friend of ours was able to
gather the necessary files that he
thought or she thought would be
interesting and sent and put them in a
GCS bucket for us so I've got here the
web chat log a sample web chat log some
Twitter information this is kind of
invoke everyone wants to do social
analytics and a web customer database so
I don't really know what's in here as I
often don't starting a project like this
I'm adding them to my flow and the first
thing you'll notice is a couple helps
for your project so you're seeing on
your left left yes yes your left is my
left you're sitting on your left the the
lineage of the data in this case I have
the the black data set which is the
actual data set and at a virtual data
set and in between them is my recipe or
set of transformations in this case
there aren't there isn't a recipe right
I haven't done anything well in fact
there might be so data prep as it loads
a data set makes some guys you know
educated guesses about the first thing
you'd want to do it tries to delimit ate
you know CSVs in two columns and that
sort of thing and so you can see in this
preview in the sidebar what data prep is
initially done in that recipe so I've my
web chat log looks just like a
unreadable log at this point so not much
done there in the case of the Twitter
file data press been able to delimit
this into some rows and similarly for
the customer database we're gonna let's
start with this Twitter 360 file
oh boy I actually knew this was coming
but I don't like it every time I see it
so this is a nested JSON like looking
thing is what I'm guessing and in fact
the the typing up here is telling me
this is an object of some kind it's all
in a single column and my histogram is
not helping too much so let me bring
this out a bit yep lots of punctuation
so I can expand one row to understand
what I'm looking at here it looks like
I've got this kind of you know nested
object two parts Twitter info user info
and in fact if I look my histogram
they're there in fact two bars
one labeled Twitter info and user info
if I click one of these bars this is
kind of one of the clicks that you could
do all throughout the UI a day to prep
the suggestion did I want to create a
new column as you're seeing here below
in the suggestions and you're saying
it's on nesting alright this is great so
I'm gonna ask these two columns I'm
gonna highlight them both I had this to
my recipe and then I'm gonna drop this
first column alright so we went from a
scary single nested objects to too scary
single there are two scary nested
objects but I think we're getting closer
so I can basically do this same thing as
I did before right yep so as I click on
a column I'm getting now the timestamp
and look at that it even knows that it's
a timestamp and so now the histograms
meaningful I'm already getting excited
so I'm gonna highlight all four of these
add these to my recipe how are we doing
is this has anybody unpacked JSON this
France before okay if you do we can talk
afterward I want I want to do what
you're doing alright then I'm going to
do the same over here so I've flattened
my my JSON file I'm gonna add this to
the recipe don't mind me I'm just
cleaning up these columns that we don't
need anymore
all right so you know in just a couple
minutes I'm totally making sense of this
and I don't even know what JSON means
right so I'm looking at this this
histogram it's a timestamp and it
actually looks like a fairly
representative histogram like I might
see like a morning peak here mid day
trough evening peak so this is a time
series histogram the others if it's not
time-based or just a Pareto you know
highest to lowest type of thing and
these all look like normal Pareto's kind
of the 8020 and this is kind of a fairly
common part of the process I'm wanting
to explore my dataset so locations got a
bunch of missing values maybe these are
optional this looks good
let's just leave this here we've got
other data sets to explore I don't quite
know what I want to do here yet oh but I
did want to make note I talked about us
operating on a sample so up here the top
we're seeing that we don't know how big
this this file is but data prep took a
10 megabyte as we expected sample of the
data set and I could choose to collect a
new sample if I wanted perfect so up
here at the top is my navigation bar
I've got my flow and then the data set
I'm in I'm gonna switch excuse me
switch over to web chat yeah I mean I
don't really like the nest of JSON and
this log file is not really doing it for
me either
all right so I told you that it's a good
place to start with the histograms so up
here at the top this histogram is
telling me nothing other than there's a
bunch of these things I'll select that
bar turns out these things are these
kind of meaningless lines that would
probably cover this trouble in the
future the suggestion is to either keep
or delete so I'm I'm choosing the second
card here if you can see that so the the
color all turned to red as a preview
that we're going to delete this
calm I haven't really fixed anything yet
but I'm feeling a little better that
I've gotten rid of that problem and then
I see there's a missing value perhaps
this was like a header or something but
if there's any empty rows I'd probably
want to get rid of them too
there it is there's my one row that
again might cause me problems in the
future I'm going to delete it the same
way all right I'm sorry to bore you with
the cleaning but it's what we do and
it's tedious and it's kind of like
flossing I'm going to select now I'm
gonna try to make sense of this so I got
this we call this unstructured data
right so this is big giant line of text
but you and I can see that there's
something in here you can probably see
that there's like a session ID there's
also a source here and what so what I
need to do is somehow communicate the
data prep some of what I'm wanting to do
so I have selected this key that makes
sense I want to probably extract the
source ID but I don't want extract just
the source ID so I'm going to highlight
this key here and now data prep has an
interesting suggestion for me it says
this is key value pairs and has to
extract the key value pairs according to
the pattern create a new column well I I
don't like these nested fields as I
mentioned but I think I think we're
moving in a direction that I can deal
with so I'm gonna add this to my recipe
now I can work over here and I see in my
now structure my semi-structured so I
went from unstructured line of text and
now I have a set semi structured object
which is not always comfortable but is
actually more usable and I can do my
little trick from our previous file
we've all learned you people are all
experts now the suggestion is to unpack
this structured object now I'm too
structured to relational data I'm going
to go ahead and do some cleanup as I've
done previously
you people all have the luxury of seeing
this from a comfortable spot but I'm I'm
up here prone to make mistake so I'm
going to clean up all right now we've
got some structured data I'm looking our
histograms and they look meaningful
useful and I'm noting that we're we're
picking up some we're Auto detecting
some some types here which is always
very exciting as you're using data prep
you're moving in the right direction I'm
seeing these two columns so source just
looks like the same URL over and over
again although I appreciate that it's
detected it's a URL and then this geo
info is still not making not making
sense to me let's take a second and
maybe so we've kind of been exploring
for a while but we probably came into
this with some inkling of what we wanted
to do we're we're measuring customer
service and web chat support maybe my
hypothesis is that wait time is going to
be a key indicator for me and I'm not
seeing wait time in any of the
information I've seen yet I am seeing
here that these are actual call logs can
everyone see this okay actually I can
zoom in further for okay so I'm seeing
actual colleagues in here like an agent
will be with you shortly
and I've seen timestamps so if I can
grab these timestamps I might be able to
approximate wait time I'm also seeing
that there's kind of two sets of data
here I have this like some key value
pairs and then a timestamps and they
seem separated about this point again
I'm going to suggest to the data prep
that maybe we should delimit eight here
if first things it's going to choose for
all the spaces I don't want all the
spaces and so in my card I can actually
let me highlight one more of these help
it out in my card I can so it wants to
split into 84 columns this is the split
card and it actually has other
suggestions within the suggestion
so the second kind of little bump here
in a suggestion is split not into 64
columns just into two that's all I want
so I'm going to select this second one
but note it's only splitting on this
like vague criteria of the space the
third one over splits into two columns
but it's a little more precise it's
after five digits and before bracket
this is I'm a little more comfortable
with this when it runs across an entire
data set so I'm gonna have that to my
recipe and as is customary drop the
column okay Oh actually I didn't want to
drop back home well this is a good time
to review what we've done so far
mistakes happen more often with me over
here on the right is our recipe so
everything all the steps I've done so
far have been collected here in the
order I've done them I can reorder these
which is a little bit scary don't do
that and I can I can delete and edit
them so I'm gonna rewind this here and
because I actually definitely don't want
to drop you info I'm going to go ahead
and delete it I mean you can see
previews along the way so this isn't too
scary of an operation when it's
previewed before okay
let's ignore the goe info we've done a
lot of key value pairs today let's try
and do this like wait time thing if I
can get to these timestamps can you
imagine trying to get these timestamps
out with sequel or with Python you'd
have to do some like regex which always
involves me going to like a browser like
read up on regex again so I'm going to
highlight a timestamp so this first one
is when I guess the chat initiated
presumably and this next one is when
it's assigned to a person so I think the
difference between that first time stamp
and the second time stamp looks
interesting so it's ready to extract
just one timestamp it's always helpful
to give data prep at least two kind of
highlights to work with now it's ready
to extract the first time stamp
it's reasonable but I want the first two
I'm gonna see if asking for additional
row additional bumps here is gonna help
and it's not helping so I'm gonna go
ahead and I'm going to actually
highlight the second time stamp
forgive me folks if I'm moving too
slowly for you but here we are we got
the first two time stamps and we're
going to extract them and you can see
them previewed over here in fact when
they get over there you can see that
again the types identified these are
time stamps awesome and add these to my
recipe so so far we've we've shown you
how to use all the suggestions I mean
this has been like point click I'm not
even doing any work but but here we're
gonna do a little work so there's
nothing really to click on to discover
wait time right I can just highlight
these things so we're going to use the
the kind of step editor it's below now
there's the step builder and editor we
don't actually throw you just into like
a blank script editor it comes with all
kinds of like autocomplete and hints and
suggestions I'm looking to like extract
or derive a value from a calculation and
here here's a derive suggestion it seems
to match what I want the formula I could
browse through some functions here to
find the formula I'm looking for there's
all kinds of analytical functions
supported I'm familiar with like a
couple date functions from my data
science days and this date diff is
basically I think what I need I'm gonna
give it the first column and say oh you
know what I could I could do this yeah
will do this I will do this like this
okay the start column is the Geo info
three and the ending column is geo info
for I want these in terms of seconds
probably hopefully my support staff
aren't waiting for hours and you see my
preview you're also seeing some data
validation so if I put you know seconds
it's not
gonna work for me as well as here I've
calculated my wait time I'm gonna add
this to my recipe and I do that as an
example to see you that you can you can
dive into these and modify these steps
is necessary now it was a little
confusing for me to refer to these as
geo info 3 & 4 so let's do a quick
rename I'm sorry well here's a view I
didn't mean to explore but you might be
benefit from so this is you could at any
point you can look at a column
distribution in detail look at the top
values of that column the histograms
let's back out of here I'm gonna rename
this at the top okay thank you so this
is initiated and we're not going well
okay I'm feeling I'm going fast and this
is a assigned time
great perfect so we've done a lot here
we got this giant table and it tells us
a lot about our users and we've also
learned along the way because this is
actually just fake data but that how did
how to edit a sample with with the
suggestions and we've also used how to
use the step builder I now want to do
something a little bit more advanced so
in this URL this source URL they all
look the same but I'm noticing there's a
URL parameter question account transfer
and these vary by some of them are
account lockout so I can do a let's
switch to the editor here I'm gonna
extract from column just give me an idea
that you can go ahead and write whatever
you want if you prefer scripting to the
mouse so in my source column I'm gonna
extract a URL parameter and because this
is tight it understands what URL
parameters are and we saw in there that
the URL parameter of interest was called
question once that's fully validated
that in fact there is a you repellant
parameter in that column called question
I add it to my recipe boom I now know
what question was asked to which rep how
long they were waiting I've done this
all on Mike we're still going 20 minutes
here folks I'm gonna keep you for the
full hour we're doing like 10 data sets
we're getting it all done today I'm
going to bed early okay dropping this
column perfect all right so we've done
now these first two data sets let's go
jump over to this customer database just
to get a view of all of them this one
comes already structured and relational
again the first thing I do is look at
the histograms I'm seeing a bunch of
missing fields here and I'm also
realizing that this isn't much of a
customer database as it really is like
looks like web analytics last complete
step I guess it could be customer
database but either way this is tracking
users through a process perhaps through
a kind of a checkout or purchase process
I'm assuming that we're wanting to get
users through all the steps and there's
several steps missing from the last of
several values missing in a last
completed step I'm gonna highlight these
missing values and as I scroll through
my data set I'm seeing that I'm actually
I'm gonna highlight these missing values
from status two so I I see here there's
succeeded incomplete terminated so the
last step either people succeeded they
terminated or they were incomplete these
empty rows are probably like they went
away and never came back
I'll make that assumption I'm going to
go ahead and modify so when I keep let's
see set status so right now I'm setting
the status to nothing I'm gonna modify
this I don't think we've done modify
before so this is a good example for you
instead of modifying to null and your
notes here there's actually some
suggestions I could modify to na I'm
gonna say no return visit and add that's
my recipe perfect I think we're done
here
so we've we've cleaned we've structured
in the case of like unnecessary enrich
these data sets they're they're only so
good alone I could do it let me go back
to my web chat file here to start a join
I'm going to select it from the
transformation editors and I'm going to
first join the web customer database you
know if I might have
looked earlier for common keys but I
don't think I need to I'm just gonna
select join keys and immediately
as mentioned earlier data prep is going
to detect and suggest common keys to
join so session works I can add
additional join keys turns out that both
customer and user ID join here now if I
were being more careful and I had more
time I'd probably confirm that these are
in fact the right keys to join on but I
did this before and they are it's okay
so I'm gonna select all the columns and
take out these duplicate columns now
I've got this giant wide table and if
any of you are familiar with some of our
data products like bigquery you know
that a giant wide table is exactly what
you want in bigquery so this is you can
use this process at home and get your
bigquery tables all set up awesome now I
can also list up there so I could join
this this Twitter data set but I think
I've got enough for the web chat and the
wedding customer database joined and I'm
gonna go ahead and run this job because
I feel like I've got everything ready
now I've enriched and I want to do my
analysis as mentioned you can use data
flow jobs within data prep - right -
either cloud storage or bigquery I'm
going to select bigquery here I happen
to have a data set ready for us I'm
going to create a new table and choose
replacement logic I've got my job
running and as data data flow starts to
run this job I'm going to show you the
monitoring interface I mentioned earlier
that you may don't want to look at this
monitoring interface but it's kind of
fun to look at at least once to get a
feel for what's happening out of the
hood so here we are as mentioned this
job has been
taken from your kind of translated from
your recipe your script into a patchy
beam Java code it's now running on data
flow we'll come back to this I actually
have let's see I did this ahead of time
so this is data studio as some of you
may know announced earlier data studio
came originally out of our analytics
offerings it's now part of cloud
platform and is available in every
country as it just recently perhaps this
week I've gone ahead and built a quick
dashboard on top of our output data and
what you're seeing here is I had that
hypothesis from the beginning like is
wait time causing bad ratings so I've
got here wait time and in one scatter
plot versus ratings and I'm actually not
seeing much of a pattern it looks like
wait time doesn't actually affect
ratings personally for me I think it
does but not in this data set I've got
this other one here which is how far
along they got in the process was it
terminated succeeded no return visit
incomplete we're also seeing that wait
time seems to play no role here but what
but the rating the customer service
rating made people twice as likely to
succeed in the process of checkout for
example so so we should be focusing on
the rating and I'm seeing over here that
my agents while they have various wait
times they're all kind of in band
nobody's waiting much longer than anyone
else but the ratings are actually quite
different and I've got these kind of two
low performers down here finally we able
to extract that question bit and from
the questions I can see that one of
these questions has a terrible wait time
in fact I'm guessing that maybe there's
a queue for that question and we haven't
we haven't quite mastered how to do this
queue or maybe we haven't fully trained
people
respond to this question I'm learning a
lot this dashboard took me maybe five
minutes to put together
you can see how quickly you know I can
edit this pretty easily drag is around
free to use give it a try let's go back
to our data flow job here you can see
how many workers were spun up some auto
scaling patterns this is a very small
job it would just use one worker nothing
really interesting to see here and I can
I wanted to go back and show you but I
didn't have it pulled up bigquery so
this is where I'm writing my datasets
you can see our giant schema we created
is here and previewed and all the data
we've written and I can bump back I have
another example here excuse me I went
fullscreen and now it's giving me
trouble
so here here's a list of I ran a bunch
of jobs earlier just so you could see
what this job list look like I've got
one currently running I've got several
completed I can show you profile results
and I'm kind of rushing here because I'm
realizing I'm running low on time but as
promised here's what job profiles that
happen look like coming out of data prep
let me if you don't mind switch me back
to my presentation I just want to wrap
up with a couple more slides we talked
through the demo what you've seen today
is you seen data prep take raw data
create refined data through the steps we
discussed earlier exploring cleaning
structure enriching and weed again this
did this in a half hour with some pretty
nasty stuff like that giant log file
nested JSON and then we've the where
this gets really interesting is you saw
that last bit how easily I can pull this
into dative studio I write it's a big
query data studio reads from bigquery
this is also powerful and important
offering for our cloud machine learning
products we're trying to democratize
artificial intelligence and machine
learning and a big part of getting
machine learning right is getting your
train data clean and so we have to
democratize data preparation as well so
I'm all of you are asking I want it now
I can see it in your eyes and that if I
weren't talking you'd all be screaming
at me a couple of points for you so you
can request early access today we we
have some companies in early access and
we're looking for more that's right
and even if we don't extend you access
we'd love to keep in touch we can give
you updates on the program and as we're
approaching public beta you can also try
this today downstairs maybe not at this
hour but definitely tomorrow that's up
to those people it's on it's in the code
labs we got one set up for you pretty
excited about it
a couple other pointers for you our UX
Desk is looking to talk to people using
our data analytics products please stop
by and I'd personally would love to talk
to you send me a tweet because then I
can analyze all my tweets and I can
analyze you and you know I will alright
that's it for me oh that's why the same
as my neck steps lies thank you so much
for your time
[Music]
[Music]